alors je maintenant je posais les veut
dire en gros si vous vivez dans cet
ouvrage lorsque jean d'ormesson voulait
poser la première question
alexandre ce jeu divine et bien
alexandre soljenitsyne vous êtes d'abord
un écrivain un grand écrivain
et c'est d'abord comme tels que nous
vous saluons ici et je voudrais si vous
le permettez vous interroger sur
certains procédés l'écrivain qui sont
évidemment assez loin de ceux auxquels
nous sommes habitués avec un zizou un
proust
quand vous êtes tout à fait isolé par
exemple vous dit maman était morte ma
mère ma femme en avait épousé un autre
tu lui écrivit pourtant pour lui dire
adieu
elle aurait pu venir prendre les
manuscrits elle ne va pas là quelque
chose de déchirant dans cette solitude
et pour lutter contre cette solitude
pour faire votre oeuvre
vous vous exercez apprendre par coeur ce
que vous écrivez
est ce que vous voulez nous dire comment
vous avez fait et comment vous avez
réussi à composer votre oeuvre
de cette façon vous n'étiez ce mr et je
n'aurais pas mis fc soler vous teniez
pour jaune
je crois que moi vivait d'une espèce de
ressorts intérieurs congères menongue
ingo des biens des années j'y vais le
mans jusqu'à 700 l'applet 40 ans nathan
l'attention de mon roman maintenant près
de vingt ans vous triez plus chaud à
l'intérieur depuis tant d'année qui
s'annonce très loin on a beau pousser au
travail a suivi de travail et incessant
cerveau soit telle était je prends la
première condition
darcos ouvert la deuxième ya tout juste
restée biyani papa style moi je crois
que je suis jamais parti en prison
bientôt jusqu'à bangkok qui me dépasse
at il même si certains écrivains
non mais yann ya signé ou béni estime je
crois pas que j'aurais pu radar est scié
soyez content mais véritable estime est
abstenu castagné à les tâches que je
vais accomplir ni la situation réelle
des pizzas mais je n'aurais pas au fond
refirent à soupe de noix la sogc rampe
vers le pénis taillables et inspira
c'est à la force moyen de conspirer pour
pouvoir acheter un pis aller le voir
travailler par conséquent brignais tient
plus qu en 2008 y est c'est la prison
qui l'a mis dans ces conditions
indispensables à la création dans ces
conditions c'est la prison c'est leur
attaque des actions de la place est-ce
que j'ai bien répondu à votre question
c'est ce que vous vouliez entendre
je pense que peut-être jean d'ormesson
vrai savoir comment vous êtes arrivé à
mémoriser des volumes entiers comment
vous êtes vous avez cultiver notre
mémoire à ce point d'amitié choisi un
siège au fonds rythme son expression
nestea au fond d'appels juste idée de
cette hantise des capacités y compris le
sa mémoire ya vu un style repères je
n'ai rien fait les études uci rollandin
cité je me fais deux minutes gestion
travailler dans six cantates et de
femmes et je n'ai jamais être me
ressaisis toute l'ampleur de la panne
qui cède sous ce capacités énormes ichi
sachent quoi de le revendre à manger les
bandes les cages je vais l'idée d'écrire
un roman sur la révolution syrienne
it has match niveau et d un enfant je
l'avais commandé un ratio niveau je vais
commencer en fait berki ses 18 ans
kristin booth tj thèmes et certaines des
scènes ou j'attaque à gorge avec qui
écrit passé tu n'as pas ton gignac
s'érige avis mais je t'ai de ci de là
l'art du nu et de braquer moi tu la
prison quand yann bonato dans cette
poule où il était impossible pour moi de
conclure sans arrêter de penser d'abord
parce que nasri matérias que l'eau
chaude
l'abc ya ce sont des privés je fasse
quelque chose pour ne pas me perdre bien
perdre mon âme est bien que je reçois je
mets peut pas mais le nouveau pays
entier dont jouissent les à bout d'os je
me suis rendu compte que sa première
longue de verre des brel et sans
aucunement l'année m'entraîner je les
écrivais moi je veux les composés par
petites portions de belwind nv il se
doit les apprenait par coeur et brûler
ce que j'avais fait sentir bien à sa
résistance et quelques 12000 j'avais
circulez il n'ya plus rien n'est pas
mort
enfin si je te dis simplement pour
répéter glaive scandinaves et yanni pour
tout juste un mois ce qui menace je
crois que dans le troisième volume de la
jupette rouge en reparle
weight aux catholiques aufschalke vous
savez il ya des gens paniquent agile il
ya des chapelets une pile direct je
tâche d'essayer déchets le chagrin ou si
la plaie non mais moi j'y cours
correspond une prière qui attaquent les
bilans il n'y a pas besoin de citer mon
brothers et je le portais dans mon livre
à lyon je leur ai dit luminaires
alors si on viendrait dire mieux ce
petit rosé jeudi ben je prie tous les
jours mais s'est contentée de charette
n'y aura personne je n'étais pas un
instrument contondant potati costumes
inédits mais quelquefois ont trouvé ces
petits fragments 2007
j'écrivais quelques verres ya eu des
manières assez terrible 1 joue en effet
être
votre exposé qui fait fi des nuits
chaîne que je lâche je suis venu en
allemand mais ce passé n'ont pas pensé
de schiste et france ô l'atv haschich et
on me donnait qu'est ce que c'est que ce
qu'il veut à des levées à loger j'essaie
de me on m'a laissé le choix ce beau
bébé d'une pièce magique et tout mon
premier steacie sauver les 20 que mass
effect latinistes et on était face à
face cinq détenus bréchet que l'appétit
six mois chaque but marqué à gauche
avaient les visages pour savoir quel
était celui de cécile bien mort in à
chaud dans la fouille était plus
j'aimerai toujours
et alors je suis à trouver surtout parce
que c'est ça je dis que c'est un
instinct naturel que je n'aime pas ce
que l'on monte un spectacle met à
sélestat nissin alors je les avais je
voyais gagner au bénin pour ne pas faire
de
pour ne pas jeter le chaudron qu'on
essaie de débris comme sur le seul la
pièce est si propre aux cimaises
d'imagés pcg bout de ses pieds dans le
creux de ma main comme dans une urne
alors je lui conseille bien